Cross-Site Request Forgery
is another web-based attack.
A user's browser may be running
a script from a good site and
also malicious script from a bad site.
This can happen when the user has
logged into the good site and
kept the session alive.
For example, the user has logged
into Gmail and has not logged off.
Meanwhile, the user maybe
browsing other sites
include the bad site that sends
malicious script to the browser.
The malicious script can then
forge a request to the good side
using the users cookie.
The good side does not know that
the request was not sent by the user,
here's an illustration.
The user logs in, and establishes
a session with a good site, and
keeps the session alive.
Meanwhile, the user browses a bad site.
For example, because he's phished.
And the browser runs a malicious
script from the bad site.
The malicious script then sends
forged requests to the good site.
Here's a realistic example.
A user logs into bank.com and
forgets to sign off.
The session cookie remains in browser.
The user then visits a malicious
website which sends an HTML page
that contains a hidden I frame that
includes this malicious content,
that is when the user's browser displays
the HTML page, actions will be performed
on the bill payment form of bank.com
as if users are entering these values.
Because the I frame is invisible
the user knows nothing about it.
The browser will send a request
on behalf of the user and
without his consent or knowledge.